hello everyone welcome my name is Daniel
Roth I'm a program manager on the
asp.net team and this in this session
we're gonna talk about modern web app
development with Blaser it is a great
time to be a software developer no
matter what type of application you're
trying to build you have loads of
frameworks libraries tools languages
runtimes to choose from for building
your application and this is also true
when building browser-based web
applications there are loads of
libraries and frameworks and languages
to use well as long as that language is
JavaScript
unfortunately javascript is the only
thing you have available to in the
browser you could compile to it but it's
the language you pretty much have to use
and there really hasn't been any way to
to address this in the browser for a
long period of time until recently
there's now a new open web standard
called web assembly that is a bytecode
for the web web assembly is intended to
be used as a compilation target the idea
is that you can take any code written in
any language and as long as you can
compile it to web assembly you can then
run that code in any browser at native
speeds web assembly is as fast and is
available anywhere in any modern browser
so of course we would like to make it
possible so that you can take your
dotnet code and target it to web
assembly so you can run your dotnet code
in any browser now why would you want to
do this why would you want to run donnah
in the browser why wouldn't you just
continue to write JavaScript well we
think there are a number of advantages
for using dotnet for full stack web
development
one is that dotnet is stable mature and
productive it has a standardized set of
api's that are matured and they're not
changing it has a standardized build
system so you have a solid foundation to
build on Donette is also also fast
scalable and reliable you can use not
NIC or for your back-end services and
get phenomenal performance Donette also
has modern innovative languages C sharp
F sharp and razor are getting a constant
stream of new and innovative features
and of course the tooling in.net has
always been first
you have Visual Studio intellisense and
great debugging now if your a.net
developer of course you already know
these things because you use net
everyday but what this means is that by
having dotnet running in the browser you
can now leverage your existing skills
and expertise so we've been working on
an experimental project to bring dotnet
to the browser so you can do full stack
web development and we call this project
blazer
what is blazer blazer is full stack web
development for dotnet via web assembly
it requires no plugins and there's no
code translation all you need is a
browser you don't need to install
anything into it we're not taking your
dotnet code and translating into
JavaScript you literally are running
normal dotnet standard libraries in the
browser it works on all modern browsers
including desktop browsers and mobile
and where does the name come from
well browser plus razor equals blazer
razor is the HTML and see sharp
templating engine that we use for Blazer
component authoring in the the blazer
framework where does the L come from we
don't know laser beams blockchain it
just sounds better so how can this
possibly work well the way blazer works
is first the first piece you need is a
web assembly based net runtime and for
that we're using model
mono is the Microsoft supported
cross-platform dotnet runtime that we
use for a client application development
for Android iOS Mac OS watches you can
pretty much run mono anywhere which
makes it a great fit for blazer
applications so we have a web assembly
implementation of a dotnet runtime we
then take your dotnet code and your
razor your razor files we compile them
into normal net assemblies and download
in them into the browser along with all
their dependencies and along with the
web assembly net runtime and then we
take the web assembly have a little bit
of JavaScript the bootstraps it executes
sit points to that your dotnet
assemblies and says run these and that's
how you can get dotnet running in the
browser so how can you get started with
this well first you're going to want to
go to blazer net
and then you're gonna need the dotnet
core SDK so make sure you have that
installed if you're just operating on
the command line you can install the
blazer templates using the.net core SDK
just dotnet new - I and type in the name
of the blazer template pack that will
work then on Windows Mac and Linux you
can do cross-platform blazer development
if you happen to be on Windows in Visual
Studio then you couldn't install our
blazer visual studio extension the
blazer language services and that will
give you the blazer templates in Visual
Studio along with the great tooling and
editing experience so let's go take a
look at doing that alright so first to
get started with blazer you're gonna
want to go to blazer dotnet and that'll
bring you to this website click on get
started and it has all the instructions
that I just went with through with you
on how what you need to install to get
blazer up and running you need a dotnet
core SDK if you're using vs install the
blazer language service extension if
you're on the command line down below
are the instructions for installing the
blazer templates on the command line
then you're ready to go to create your
first blazer app alright so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that let's go into visual
studio I've already installed the blade
the blank blazer extension you can see
that in my extensions and updates'
if we search for blazer here there it is
installed if you want to install the
link the extension you can just search
for it here and you'll find it online
alright so now let's create a new blazer
wrap so file new project let's call this
blazer one and I'm going to create a web
application you create it through the a
snit core web app dialog
and then I'm just going to create a
default normal blazer application there
are these other two templates and we'll
talk a little bit more about those later
all right so let's create one all right
cool now to see what this app does I'm
just going to go ahead and build and run
it and of course we should let the new
get packages restore first try it again
where it goes and this should bring me
up my first dotnet in the browser web
application alright so let's see what we
got here so this application is using
bootstrap 4 for styling and it just has
a couple of tabs on the left hand side
there's a home page with just some
content there's a little link to a
survey if you'd like to give us some
feedback on Blaser we'd love to hear
from you then there's this counter page
which just has a button when you click
the button and it increments a counter
and then on the fetch data page there's
a table rendered with some weather
forecast data that's being fetched from
the server so this counter can page
every time I click this button it is
actually executing dotnet code it's
executing c-sharp to update the UI
there's no page refresh happening to go
back to the server so how does that what
does that look like to implement if we
go back to the application look at the
pages and you can see that that my
Blaser application is entirely made up
of c-sharp and razer files each of the
Razr files defines Blaser components so
let's look at the counter component and
see what it's got ok well up at the top
you see that this is a component that
has a route it is a routable component
to browse through this route i browse to
slash counter and then there's some
normal markup and some razor syntax it's
rendering a label that's displaying the
curtain count using razor syntax and
then a button that has an onclick
handler that happens and every time the
button is clicked but this isn't a
javascript click handler this is written
in c-sharp so down below in this
functions block the functions block adds
a bunch of members and methods to the
generated class that comes out of this
razor file as part of the build a rate a
blazer component is just a normal dotnet
class so this this method gets added to
the class when it's built and you can
see we just have an increment count
method that increments the current count
int field that's it so every time I'm
clicking this button I'm actually
calling that that function and now so
these are components you can define
components using razor files and then
when you want to use them you use them
using normal HTML element like syntax so
let's go look at the index page the home
page for this application that was this
page here currently just has some static
markup and then this
if we look at how that was implemented
it's just static HTML again it's a it's
a routable component it has a route well
then there's this survey prompt
component that's being used to render
this little part of the page where we're
asking you to click on the survey link
so that is an example of a component so
you just use it using normal element
syntax so for example if I wanted to use
the counter component
well the name of the element just
matches the name of the type that gets
generated from the Razr file so I should
be able to add a counter component here
by just typing counter and there it is
you can see you get nice and tella sense
over your components all right so let's
go ahead and complete that and this
should give me actually like the self
closing syntax there we go this should
give me a counter component a separate
one rendered on the home page let's
refresh the application and see if that
works
yes yeah so now we've got another
counter component right on the home page
in addition to the one that's routable
the one that's off of the tab all right
cool so you can reuse components you are
using normal HTML element like syntax
components can also take parameters they
can take data that they can use as part
of their rendering logic like for
example this survey prompt component
actually takes a parameter this title
parameter we can do the same thing with
our counter component let's update it to
take a parameter as well so I'm going to
go into counter and I'm going to add a
parameter we have a nice little snippet
in vs that you can use just type PA RA
for short for parameter and tab that in
and there we go so our parameter is just
a property that is attributed with
parameter and so I want ya I want an int
parameter and I'm gonna call this one
increment amount and this is going to be
the amount that I would like to
increment every single time I click the
button so by default let's just make
that one that should be good and then
down below let's use our parameter let's
increment now by increment amount using
almost c-sharp syntax ok that looks good
now if I go back to the home page to
where I had this counter component let's
set the parameter so if I start typing
increment aha
so I get nice and tell a sense over my
new parameter that had added to the
component so let's go ahead and add that
and let's make the home page counter
increment by 10 so we go back let's
refresh
and we should see the counter component
and now when I click it it did commence
by ten sweet the other one should still
continue to increment by one because I
didn't set the increment amount
parameter on that component great so
that's working great all right now let's
take a look at this fetch data component
so this component is actually issuing an
HTTP request to the backend to pull down
some JSON data deserializing that in the
browser in order to then render this
table using raiser logic let me show you
what that implementation looks like so
here is fetch data okay at the top again
we have a route this is a routable
component and then what's this @inject
thing well at inject is the Razr syntax
that you use to inject services into
Razer or into in this case a blazer
component the way the syntax works is
the first token is basically the type of
the service that you'd like to inject
and the second token is the name of the
property really that you'd like to
populate with that particular service so
here I'm actually injecting an HTTP
client into the fetch data component
Blaser provides an HTTP client as a
service as part of the the runtime and
it's already pre-configured with the
right base address to talk back to the
to the hosting server alright cool so I
should now be able to use this HTTP
property in the code if we look down now
at the rest of the fetch data component
there's a bunch of razor logic for just
rendering out a table that looks normal
let's jump down here to the to the code
and if we look at the code we have a
method that will be called when the
component is initialized when the
component is initialize we use that HP
client to issue a get request to the
server in this case the JSON data is
just a static file like we can see it
actually in the WWE root folder under
the sample data folder there there it is
so there's just the static jason data in
this case we can improve on that in just
a bit but it retrieves that JSON data
DC realizes it using a little jason
helper into weather forecast array which
is then saved and as a field on the
component the weather forecast type is
inlined here in the the component just
for convenience and then up above we're
just looping over that array using
normal razor syntax to render out the
table data so that's how you can issue
HP requests also from your
and also use dependency injection to
inject services when you configure your
services like where does that actually
go well blazer apps have a start up
class kind of like asp.net core apps but
remember blazer apps are running
client-side in the browser they're not a
server application so my startup class
has the standard two methods configure
services that's where you would add any
services that you want to add blazer
adds the HP client automatically for you
in the configure method this is where
we're actually setting up the root
component for our application in this
case my root component is the app
component where is that defined well
that's over here in app dot CS HTML and
if we look at that guy it's all it has
is a single component in it which is a
built in component that's provided by
blazer call it's called the router
component and the router component is
what actually handles finding all of the
routable components in your application
and making sure that requests go to the
right component to render that's all it
really does now if we look back at that
startup class once more there's also a
an element selector that's saying where
do we want this blazer component to
actually be rendered that the route of
the Blazer app is actually just a static
HTML file if we go up again to our
dub-dub-dub root folder and go to the
index dot HTML file this is just static
HTML but here you can see there's that
app element that we're telling blazer
replace that app element with the app
component with the rendered output of
the app component you can also see here
the script tag that's setting up the the
bootstrapping JavaScript that will fire
up the web assembly down at runtime and
point it at your app so that's where all
the the Blazer stuff gets wired up ok so
then what actually gets downloaded by
this application
let's f12 in the browser and take a look
at the the network traffic all right
cool so let's see we have at the top we
have the that static index.html file did
the the rendered HTML and then we have
bootstrap styling and stuff that's being
pulled down because this app uses a
bootstrap all right and then here's the
boot the different kind of bootstrapping
the the JavaScript that blazer uses to
fire up the dotnet runtime now where is
the actual dumpin at runtime it's a
little further down and that is this guy
here mano Dahl Azzam dot waz 'm is the
extension used for
webassembly files that are executed in
the browser and that is a full dotnet
runtime implemented in web assembly and
then you can see right below it there's
my application blazer app one DLL on
normal DLL being downloaded into the
browser along with all of its
dependencies that is then being executed
using that dot at runtime so that's
pretty cool now how big is this
application if we go all the way to the
bottom and look at the size it is one
point one point eight megabytes
compressed so I mean that's pretty small
for having a full dotnet runtime for a
web app it's a it's a admittedly a
little bit big now some folks might say
oh but you could we could mitigate this
using like HTTP caching we could cache
the the web assembly file and a lot of
the dotnet base class library assemblies
and that's absolutely true
but we still think we can do better we
think we can get this size down even
smaller we're already doing what we call
il linking where we go through the the
dll's that are produced from your blazer
application and we strip out all of the
unused il as best we can right now some
work that still needs to be done to make
that even smarter and we think we can we
can do that like we could probably strip
out more code reduce the size of the web
assembly runtime itself and we hope to
get this down you know under am a ghost
or we'd like to shoot for asp.net core
2.2 also has support for a broadly
compression so that would help reduce
this size even more alright great so
that's how the blazer app actually runs
and gets executed alright cool so what
about debugging though so you have this
done at runtime running in the browser
but how do you debug your code I mean
you can't just use the normal chrome dev
tools for example or whatever dev tools
you like because you're not you're not
running JavaScript so how do you do that
well we do actually have some early work
that we've done on enabling debugging
for Blaser applications directly in the
browser and I'll show you how that works
so first of all if you go look at the
console out of the in the browser you'll
see that it adds this hot key for doing
debugging of your blazer applications
shift all T so let's let's give that a
try and see if that works for us
ok so this opens up another tab and what
it's going to try and do is its
well it obviously didn't work let's
let's find out why or understand why
this separate tab is actually going to
try and take the chrome dev tools and
point it at a blazer debugging server
which then is pointed at the the actual
application that you want to debug that
debugging server will talk to the to the
browser using the standard debugging
protocol for that we know would be used
for JavaScript but on mented with dotnet
specific information now in order to
enable that hop you actually have to
open Chrome in remote debugging mode so
that's what this error is telling me to
do so just go just go to copy the
command that it's telling you to execute
I'm gonna close all the the browser
instances and let's run Chrome now with
remote debugging enabled let's get it up
and running okay let's do a shift alt e'
again and hopefully this time you should
have some luck okay so i got the chrome
debugging tools up let's put them over
to the side Oh No so they've got this
reconnect bug again that's gonna work
ah okay hold on a second well a second
let's see if we can fix this now the
bugging supporting for this setup is
immediately pretty pretty flaky right
now like right now it's mostly proof of
concept to show that it can be made to
work but there be there be edges let me
see if I can just get this to clear out
by going into the the local storage and
clearing out some stuff so whether local
storage everything there Kay local
storage dot see if we can was it clear
yeah clear okay great so then let's try
it let's try it one more time I'm gonna
try it once more
let's see we can get this to work all
right let's put it over here and let's
put the app over here all right and now
we want to let's see if we can see our
sources all right cool okay so now you
see over here in the sources I can now
see blazer app one DLL whoa what is that
and if I expand that I can now see all
of the Razr files for my application so
I'm gonna let's look at counter and yep
I can see the
the the c-sharp code the razer code for
the counter i'm going to set a
breakpoint on the counter component
let's click it and voila we hit
breakpoint debugging in the browser of
dotnet code now this is really really
early like like you've already seen
there's lots of edge cases we still need
to do a little bunch work to napal be
able to see locals and make the stepping
really work well but at least we have a
proof of concept to show that this is
absolutely possible in the future we
want to make it so that you can just f5
in Visual Studio and have this already
set up so you can already go ahead and
debug without having to do any
additional jumps we'd even like to make
it so that you can do you know script
source debugging of your c-sharp code
directly from vs while the app is
running and visuals in in in the browser
and we think we believe that is possible
as well so that's that's a new early
look at a proof of concept debugging all
right let's close this down all right
cool now what about publishing when you
publish this application what you end up
with is just a bunch of static files
remember this is a completely
client-side solution those static files
can then be hosted on any server that
supposed support static file hosting
that could be the Azure set on hosted as
an azure static site you could host it
on github pages like we even have a
blazer app that's already set up that
way there's a blazer demo github that I
oh well this is an early slightly
earlier version or blazer I think it's
still in bootstrap 3 but this is a
blazer app hosted just as static files
as on github pages so you can host it
wherever you want you don't need to have
Donette on the server but if you do have
done it on the server we can enable a
lot more experiences so just like you
can host blazer anywhere you could also
host it in an asp.net core web
application so let's take a look at what
that looks like so let's do file a new
project now let's leave this this simple
app ok so let's do let's create call
this one hosted blazer app and then
instead of picking the default blazer
template now let's now pick this blazer
asp.net core hosted template so that we
can
host our blazer app in asp.net core and
use dotnet no on both sides of the wire
alright cool
so what do we got here so now we have a
solution we're three projects so let's
take a look what these are so there's a
client project a server project and a
shared project so the client project is
just a normal blazer app like we just
saw a few minutes ago that's going to
have our Blazer components that's going
to have all the normal blazer stuff the
dot server project that is an asp.net
core project and we're going to use it
to host the output of our blazer client
project dot shared is just a normal
dotnet standard class library and it's
referenced by both the client the blazer
client and the server so that we can
have code that is shared on both sides
of the wire so let's take a look at what
that looks like
so the plays a client looks just like it
did before in fact let's let's run this
app so we can see that it's functionally
the same while that's going on building
will expand it here we see we have our
counter component our fetch data
component all the normal stuff let's let
it go ahead and run cool all right it's
loading
okay and so we have our count
we have our fetch data component as well
now in this case though fetch data
instead of going and just pulling down a
static file it's actually calling an API
that's hosted in our asp.net core
application in the dot server
application so let's see that there so
in that server now we can see we have a
controllers folder and it actually has
an API controller that's just returning
some ran random weather forecast data
that's at least dynamic all right so
that's nice now how do how do you set
this up so that you host blaze or in
asp.net core well it's pretty pretty
easy first thing you need to do is you
just have a project reference so the
server project references the Blaser
client project that it wants to host
okay so you set up a normal project
reference and then second in your
startup class for the server side in the
asp.net core you add a piece of
middleware this use blazer call okay and
then you point at the at a type for the
blazer app that you want to host and now
this will set up your application so
we'll work both during development and
it will also work when you publish the
server application it will build the
blazer app collects all the stuff that
it needs in order to run and then make
that available to the server
applications so that it can be served up
as a static files so that's kind of nice
now this the.net standard class library
it has code now that's shared between
both projects if we look in there we see
we have this weather forecast type
that's the same weather forecast we type
we saw before that was sort of inlined
in the in the fetch data component now
it's in a dotnet standard class library
so it can be shared if we look back at
the controller we can see that the
controller is returning that weather
forecast type the same one and then on
the client when it does the fetch the
fetch call using the HP client now this
type is no longer defined in line it's
just being reused from that dotnet
standard class library Blaser supports
running pretty much any dotnet standard
class library that's out there with some
limitations based on the limitations of
the browser so like there's obviously
things that you can't do from a browser
that don''t standard library might try
to do like you can't go off and just
randomly touch the the filesystem in
those cases Blaser will will throw and
not support it exception to let you know
that you're doing something that's not
going to work in the in the browser
all right great so that's a full stack
now dotnet web development
with with blazer now it's interesting to
look at this vegetative component
because I kind of glossed over something
earlier there's this HP client that's
being injected to make the HP call to
the server but wait a minute like how
does that work like this is a managed
dotnet type how does it actually do a
network call to the server well the way
that works is through JavaScript Interop
web assembly code can call into any
JavaScript function through JavaScript
Interop and we surface that capability
in Blaser in fact that's actually how
blazer fundamentally works when you have
your blazer components and we and the
blazer runtime executes their rendering
logic the components actually render
into a rendering tree and in-memory
representation of the of the browser DOM
and then the Blazer keeps track of what
was previously rendered and what was
newly rendered and does a diff and then
it goes once it's calculated that diff
it then applies that diff to the actual
browser Dom using JavaScript Interop
that's how it actually makes those calls
that's how it's able to do Dom
manipulation you can't actually
manipulate the Dom directly from web
assembly code but you can absolutely do
it through JavaScript Interop this HP
client in code is working in a very
similar way remember eight this HP
client came comes as a service in a
blazer application and owner to the
covers we've actually swapped out the
underlying message handler that it's
using to add some JavaScript Interop
code so that it uses the browser fetch
API to actually make the network call so
that's how that's working that's
JavaScript Interop in in action now you
can use JavaScript Interop yourself as
well for example you might want to do
this to call arbitrary browser api's
maybe you want to access local storage
maybe you want to use the canvas api
maybe you like to use the payment api
there's lots of native capability of the
browser that you'd like to be able to
use you can use JavaScript Interop to do
that you might also have existing
JavaScript libraries that you would like
to continue to leverage you can use
JavaScript Interop to call those
libraries from dotnet code and we can
look at how to do that and in fact we
have a template that we provide you I
prayed a blazer class library template
that you can add JavaScript Interop code
to
and then you can build it and package it
up as a new get package and share it
with other people effectively
shrink-wrapping a javascript call in a
dotnet library that people can then use
to call that javascript as if it were
just normal dotnet so let's see how we
do that so unfortunately the template
isn't actually exposed from within
Visual Studio but we can use it from the
command line so I'm gonna jump to the
command line here let's just go into
command prompt all right
and then let's do dotnet new to see all
the templates that I have installed
currently let's expand to make a little
bigger you can see that I have a blazer
host a nation that blazer library
template have all the Blazer templates
that are available here from DotNetNuke
from dot from the dotnet core SDK now
these don't get installed with the
Visual Studio extension you do need to
install these separately the way you do
that is you just say dotnet new - I and
then you put the package ID for the
blazer template pack which is ASB net
cord laser dot templates okay and that
will give you these templates available
from from the command line including
this nice blazer library template blazer
lip so that's great one of those so I'm
gonna do net new blazer lib and let's
put it in I don't pleaser lib one that's
probably okay alright great so now we've
created the project we can jump back to
visual studio now so let's add that
project to our solution alright let's do
let's go to my actual code this is a
hosted blazer app one and there's blazer
blip one there this lets out that one
alright cool so what is in this blazer
class library well first of all it has
this example JavaScript Interop class
which shows you how to do c-sharp to.net
Interop and so what it is it's just a
static class that has a you know in this
case it's a prompt method and here it's
going to call into the JavaScript prompt
function and the way you do that is you
get a handle first on the JavaScript
runtime using JSON time current and then
you can call invoke a
sink and you pass in a path to the
JavaScript function that you want to
call miss path is relative to the to the
window object you can then pass in any
dotnet any parameters that you want to
use for calling that JavaScript function
and bleh the the the entropic P I will
take care of marshaling those parameters
over to the JavaScript side you can then
specify the return type of what you'd
like back in this case you just get the
string back from the result of the the
prompt so this has a little bit of
JavaScript that goes along with it let's
see where that is in the content yes so
example J's Interop J s great so here's
just a little bit of JavaScript we've
set up an example J's functions function
with the show prompt function and it all
does is call prompt and type in a prompt
in and it returns a string so now we
have a dante p dot n api that we can use
to call the prompt function that we can
use from anywhere in fact the blazer
class library template will take care of
bundling up all of the static assets
that are used by the library and embed
them as embedded resources into the
library so that you can then reference
that library very conveniently okay so
lets reference it so let's go to my
client and let's add a reference to the
Blazer Lib library there we go alright
and now let's add some code that's
that's called the prompt function so
let's go let's say the the homepage
looks like a good place and what we want
to do in here let's add a button and
call it prompt and let's add a handler
on here on click and then in here I'd
like to call a ìdonít method that will
use JavaScript Interop to call prompt so
let's add a functions block okay and
then now JavaScript functions they're
they're async I hope you saw that it was
tasks of string that it returned so we
need an async function so let's do a
sync task and let's do let's just call
this method prompt as well prompt and
then okay so now we need we probably
need a using statement for Blazer lib
way to lib one is that there yeah okay
completed and now we should be able to
call it so example J
just interrupt perfect and let's call
the pump function so this is the stat
that static function that sat at static
method that will call the JavaScript
function and what does this look this
takes a method so hello from net okay
and let's await this and get it back and
so it's actually have a little message
here let's do a string message and let's
populate that message with the result
from calling the prop function okay
great and so now let's do at prompt
should should give me the method yeah
okay so I got Intelli since they're from
completing my dotnet method name and
let's render out the message that we
also got back so I don't know her
through a paragraph and message okay
cool
so let's go back to the app home page
and let's refresh
we should have a button now that says
prompt if everything builds correctly
there it is okay if I click prompt well
we just called in to JavaScript says
hello from dotnet calling the JavaScript
in the air will it say hello from
JavaScript back to net returns the
string and it renders it to the screen
so that's how you can call any
JavaScript function you want from a
place or app and likewise from
JavaScript you can call back into the
dotnet there's a pattern for doing that
as well for like doing it vent handling
and those types of things now
the only thing better than doing a
JavaScript Interop though is having
someone else do JavaScript Interop for
you so there are all sorts of people in
the blazer community that have been
already building blazer class libraries
that shrink-wrap existing JavaScript API
is we've done at AP is so you can just
use them so for example if I go back to
the counter page right now if I you know
count up to 11 and then I refresh the
browser be nice if that actually stayed
at 11 but it doesn't because it's just
held in memory it's not actually stored
anywhere now if you're you do a lot of
browser development you would think oh
well I can solve that I can just store
the current count in local storage and I
could use some JavaScript to do that but
when it wouldn't be nice if I could do
that in dotnet so we're gonna do that
and we're going to do that using a
community package on the Blazer dotnet
site if we go to slash let's just go to
there and then we'll click on community
there are all sorts of libraries that
folks in the community have been
building that give you a bunch of
pre-built blazer components and
JavaScript Interop libraries that you
can use as well as a whole bunch of
sample apps if you want to take a look
at those and so let's use one of these
I'm going to use the blazer extensions
storage library so let's let's go up to
my student in my app let's add to my
client app a new package okay and let's
use its blazer extensions I think
there's a whole bunch of them yeah
there's a whole bunch of them here you
can do logging storage there's a signal
our client there's one for the the
canvas API and this is just from from
one org they're a bunch of other ones as
well I'm gonna I'm gonna grab this
storage library this will handle both
session storage and local storage and
let's just install that into my Blaser
client
currently we encountered a yes lint
parsing error someplace that work I hope
that worked they're not sure what
happened there all right let's see if we
can still use it okay now to use this
but I've read the docs for this library
and the way you use it you need to
actually add it to your services so
let's do services dot and storage I
think is what it is
yep so there's the name space blazer
extension storage that's the service I
just added so it did something
so hopefully that this all worked just
fine and now let's see if we can use the
storage API from the counter page so
what are we gonna do here let's well
first of all by adding the local storage
support as a surface I now can inject
support for local storage here so I
think that's how to using statements to
make this easier laser extensions
storage is the name space used by this
library and then I want a local storage
service and let's just call it local
storage for the property name great ok
now every time I click that button
here's what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
save that to local storage so let's do
local storage use accessing that
property so I set I know I think it's
the name of the API yeah that looks
right ok so set item and then what we
got to do we got to give it a key let's
call it counter and then the value I'm
going to put in is the current count
all right great now this is I believe an
async call but that should be fine like
it'll just light a fire and if it
doesn't complete it's okay all right but
when the component reloads though we
want to be able to rehydrate to that
state out of local storage so I'm gonna
now add a on init method I mean it a
sink because we're gonna read something
out asynchronously a little formatting
goof there ok let's make this guy async
and in here let's also ask access local
storage but let's read out of it so
local storage that would probably get
item yeah get item and we're gonna
return a string we're now string an int
out of local storage and the key again
is counter yes I know I should probably
have that string someplace common and
then we'll just populate current count
with the value that we get out of local
storage okay great so I didn't have to
write any JavaScript Interop code code
myself I just let someone else in the
community do that for me because they do
a great job okay let's go back to the
app and see if it's still working okay
so let's say five is it building
all right cool so it's loading now we
can click up the counter up to 11 and
hopefully if I did this right right
refresh it should say still 11 it is
awesome okay now if we actually go into
the browser the browser dev tools and
into the console and let's look at local
storage we can see that there is in fact
a value counter and it's got some some
stuff in it so that's cool all right so
that's how you can do consume community
libraries for doing JavaScript Interop
so you don't have to write all that
stuff yourself all right what else can
we do with a blazer class library well
you can also share component
implementations the fact this blazer
class library has a component
implementation in it there's this
component one CSS HTML that's in this
library it's just a bunch of static
content but that's fine but it also has
some particular styling that goes along
with it there's a background image that
it uses can we use this component from
our application hopefully yes now there
is one little ugly thing that we do have
to do this is just a temporary thing
right now with the way Blazer works in
order to get the tooling to work we do
have to say add tag helper star from I
think blazer live one so that's that's
just a little thing that you currently
have to do when consuming components
from a component blazer component class
library in the future that won't be
necessary but for right now it is
alright now let's see if we can use that
component one from our home page let's
add it let's just add it right here so
can we see component 1 it's now showing
up so we've got component 1 in our
application so let's complete that let's
just close it and save let's go back to
the browser to the home page and see if
we can see component 1 now showing up
and it is and you can tell that it's
also picking up the like the background
image and the custom styling from the
blazer class library because it's got
this stripy background and this dotted
red line on the outline that's all done
with with with CSS the background is
done with an image so now you can build
your own components put them in
libraries package them up in nougat
packages and share them with the
community a bunch of those also are
available on that blazer community page
so if you're looking for some existing
component libraries you can find them
there alright cool so that's components
now I think let's look at a slightly
more involved application so what do I
do this so let's go ahead and select a
visual studio and let's close this
project we have a sample application
that we've published and on the a spinet
org
I think it's also linked from here as it
is available here I don't remember slide
finders now if not published on this
site but you can actually I think it's
on the the getting started instructions
at the very end if you want to see this
particular flight finder sample I think
it's at the end of build your first app
so go all the way down the bottom after
doing all this stuff you can find a link
to this flight finder sample that I'm
going to show you now so let's go ahead
and open up flight finder there it is
this is a slightly more involved
application but if we look at the
solution structure it looks like the a
speak or hosted project that we saw
previously it's got a client's got a
server it's got a shared a shared
library between them if we look at the
shared library it's got all sorts of
model types that are being shared
between the client and the server let's
run it so we know actually what it does
this app basically you can think of it
as like a mini travel site where you're
searching for flights we can say like
where do we want to we can go from some
point A to point B well here we're going
from Seattle from where is this from
from London to to Seattle you can select
your your departure time and arrival
time and I don't even know if like
validations set up to check for those
things but if we search it just returns
some random flight data that is not
based on anything in real life it's just
randomly generated but then for each of
these flight results that come back you
can add them to a
list that appears on the right-hand side
so there's sort of three basic
high-level components here there's this
search component there's the flight
search results component and then
there's the short list on the right-hand
side and we can see that if we look at
the Blazer client app for this this
application and let's look at this main
CS HTML component the main component you
can see that yeah there's the search
component there's the search results
wrapped in this grey out zone we'll talk
about that in a second and then there's
the short list component that's rendered
on the the right-hand side all right so
that's cool now there is something
interesting up here at the top this
@inject app state what is that well
blazer itself is very unimaginative
there are loads of people who have lots
of opinions and how you should do this
you know i observables or i property
notified channel all sorts of patterns
that you could use to manage state in
your app and but the community seems to
have centered on a particular approach
which is to use a state container so
that all of the app state is is managed
in one places now if you're using
existing JavaScript frameworks they have
in fact built frameworks for
implementing state containers like redux
and so forth that you can then use in
your app in this application it's using
a little mini state container that the
app just implements itself this app
state class is just managing all of the
state of the class and making sure
everyone that needs to know about state
changes knows about it but there are
also community projects now available
for managing state if we go back to that
community page and we just such a search
for State like there are people who have
done dotnet ports of redux that you can
try out a flux you can try that one out
I think there was one of them Oh bik's
that we saw recently and we keep finding
about more about them every day all
right and every week so you could
absolutely use one of those this
application just is fairly simple so it
uses a fairly simple state management
solution so that's what that's doing
that app state is not it's not a blazer
runtime thing it's a an app specific way
of managing the state of the application
cool okay well what else is interesting
in this application well the it has its
um
web api is on the back end that are used
to serve up the data here's where the
airport list comes from is just a
hard-coded list of airports and here's
the a Smith Corps flight search
controller that's used to generate all
the random data that you're seeing so it
is you know full stack web development
again with with net now one thing I
wanted to show you here that's kind of
interesting is a higher level component
that this app uses and that's this
behavior that you see when I click the
search button well the search button is
going to do a Web API request the
backend and that could take a little
while and while it's doing that you you
you'd rather not just keep displaying
you know the the previous search results
because then you don't know like are
those the a new search results or the
old ones so instead what it does when
you click the search button you can see
it sort of Gray's out that search
results section so that you can't
interact with the that part of the UI
until the search results have app have
actually been returned now how is that
implemented well that's done with this
grey out zone component remember seeing
that in main this grey out zone is is
around the search results component and
how is that guy implemented what does it
do well let's look at its implementation
so it has a div and the div has a class
that is conditional based on a parameter
so there's a is grayed out boolean
parameter that this component takes if
it's true then it sets the gray out
class otherwise no class inside of that
div there's another div which is this
cover div and so what happens is if the
is greyed out parameter is set to true
then there's some CSS that will
basically expand this cover over the
based on the size of the parent
component and put an overlay over the UI
that sort of translucent gray so that
you can't interact with it
now this component interesting enough
was implemented in such a way that he
could surround any arbitrary content you
can see it's doing this at child content
thing here what is that
well components can capture their child
content and then use that as part of
their rendering so down below we have a
second parameter which is this child
content parameter and it's of type
render fragment and that render fragment
captures the child content of the
component remember the main component it
was wrapping the search result so it'll
capture this stuff
and then you can in your component
authoring decide where you would like to
render the child content so that's how
that works that's sort of a higher-level
component where components can have
child content that they capture and use
this part of their rendering and you
should absolutely play around this app
does a lot of other interesting things
it's available on github
alright let's now go back here so that
is a little bit of blazer so we've seen
a lot of things blazer as a UI framework
already has quite a few features even
though it is experimental it has a
fairly rich component model it supports
routing client-side routing it has a
notion of layouts we didn't really look
at that in detail but it's fairly
straightforward IDE supports dependency
injection JavaScript Interop when you
change the code you can just refresh the
browser because it will auto build on
the bin in the background on the fly we
have some very early support for
debugging in the browser we support
publishing we do app size trimming to
reduce the size of your application by
trimming unused il we also and we didn't
show this but but this is supported by
the runtime we support falling back to
an atom J s space runtime in the event
that the browser doesn't actually
support web assembly so that you could
potentially work in older browsers it'll
be a little larger a little slower but
it can still be functional and then last
thing you saw that we have rich
intellisense in our tooling and editing
experience ok next one I talked a little
bit about hosting models for for blazer
so Moton the apps that we looked at
we're all blazer running client-side in
the browser they actually are running
directly in the browser UI thread you
download the runtime the blazar app you
have a little Java Script that fires off
Blaser events are happening in
JavaScript that are blazars in handling
and giving to components and they're
rendering and the Dom's getting updated
all that's actually happening directly
on the UI thread today but Blaser was
architected in such a way that all that
work could actually happen in a in a
separate process so for example maybe
you'd like to actually move all that
blazer logic into a web worker and have
only and then through messaging handle
all the dom diff updates to the UI and
all the UI events coming from from the
user and Blaser was architected in order
to support that this is
something that we have available today
but it was built with this pattern in
mind when we were looking at this and
we're like hot well that that actually
enables a bunch of interesting scenarios
where you can use the blazer UI
framework for scenarios other than just
client-side browser development for
example maybe you'd like to use blazer
with electron-electron is a
cross-platform desktop app framework
which is basically a chromium a browser
shell that's been wrapped in a process
that you can use to build desktop
applications that run on Windows Mac and
Linux so we did a prototype where we
took blazer and instead of running it on
a web assembly based dotnet runtime we
just run it on normal net core and then
we communicate with electron over an IPC
channel so that we can handle the UI
events from from the browser and then
push back the the Dom diffs to update
the the Dom in the browser so let's take
a quick look at that today and what that
what that looks like this is just you
know prototype proof of concept but it's
fun to play with all right so let's go
here okay so on github github Steve
Sanderson's
repo blazer electron experiment sample I
think this one is actually on the
community page so we search for electron
here yeah so the electron sample you can
find on this in the sample section on
the community page if we just do dotnet
run here what this is going to do is
this gonna fire off a dotnet core
process which is then going to fire up
electron and it will set up an IPC
channel with electrons so that it can
handle all the UI interactions but
there's no web assembly involved here
you're actually running on normal dotnet
core but it looks exactly the same so
instead of writing my electron app with
with a bunch of JavaScript I can
actually now write it in net and this
application will run cross-platform on
Windows Mac and Linux so that's kind of
interesting you know an opportunity to
write cross-platform desktop
applications using web technologies and
and.net alright so that's okay it's kind
of an interesting model what else could
we do well we started thinking about
this and we're like huh well blazer
supports out of process rendering what
if we took that channel and stretched it
out Oh
the entire network in that way you could
actually take the Blazer UI model the UI
framework and run it on this server and
then you set up a signal our connection
to the browser you know 2-way real-time
connection with the browser and have a
little bit of JavaScript running the
browser so that you can send any UI
events to the server have your
components run do the Dom dipping and
then send the the Dom diff back down to
the to the browser and we call this
model server-side blazer and the nice
thing about this is well okay well
webassembly again isn't even in the
picture here there's no issues with like
how do we do debugging how do we you
know get the the runtime to be
performant you know figuring out how to
run a done at runtime a web assembly in
this case the runtime is a known
quantity it's just dotnet core so
debugging works all your normal
libraries work and we have a template
that's that tries out this experience
that we'd like to share with you so
let's let's go back to vs again let's do
a file new project and said this time
let's we call this server-side laser one
okay and I'm going to pick this third
template server-side in asp.net core and
this template is set up to actually run
Blaser on the server with a signaler
connection set up to the client so we
have we have two projects in this in
this template there's dot server that's
the a spinet core project and dot app
that's the the normal blazer project
okay if we run this it has some
different behaviors but the programming
model is fundamentally the same so the
app will look the same it has a chance
to build there it goes okay well now I
want you to notice that as I refresh
like this app you know reloads super
fast like the client-side apps you know
it takes a little while to download the
web assembly you've done it runtime and
get it running whereas this server-side
version runs really really quick and
that's because we're downloading very
very little we're not downloading a
donna at runtime
we're just downloading a little bit of
JavaScript we can look at the that the
network that's control f5 just to see
what actually got downloaded you know
the download size now instead of being
1.8 Meg's is under 100 kilobytes
okay and there's very
little coming down there's no dll's
there's no doubt Azzam that's all in all
being handled on the server so superfast
startup time other things that are
interesting with because it's running on
the server
normal dotnet stuff just works you can
reference normal dotnet libraries you
don't have all the limitations of the
browser you can also debug things so
let's go to our counter component let's
just set a breakpoint on the counter
component f5 so now we're gonna be
running the dotnet code that's running
on the server under the debugger there's
no dot no code actually running
client-side in this case although we
wrote our whole app with C sharp and and
dotnet and now if I click on the counter
and click click I hit my breakpoint on
on the server the experience let's let's
remove the breakpoint and just make sure
we see the experience it's still the
same like there's no refresh happening
here you still get that rich interactive
feel of a single page app like model but
it's all implemented on the server and
handling all the UI interactions over a
real-time Channel so we think this is an
interesting model and we're we it's it's
because it has so it's less experimental
we're actually planning to ship this
with.net core 3 oh now as we do that
we're planning to still continuing to
preserve the client-side model the
component model will stay the same
whether you're running on the server or
on the client so that we can continue to
make progress on dotnet in the browser
because that at the end at the end of
the day is really the goal here we're
using server-side Blaser as a path to
get to dotnet on the browser we can
continue to make progress on the UI
framework while the webassembly dotnet
runtime matures so let me show you how
you can take this server-side app and
you can actually flip it to be a
client-side app without really changing
any code so let's go back to the app and
stop the debugger and now let's go and
just gonna make a couple changes so in
the startup class for the server-side
blazer application instead of saying use
blazer it's currently saying use
server-side blazer and that's the call
that actually will set up the the signal
our hub and the channel and all the
infrastructure needed to do runs blade
the blazer components on the server
there's also a call in the add services
configure services method to add the
services needed for server-side
which unifies the service provider with
the one used by the Blazer app okay but
what if we just changed this back to use
blazer all right and then we have to do
one other thing let's go back to the app
the app has a slightly different
index.html file instead of using blazer
that webassembly is it's using blaze
without server Jas that's just a little
JavaScript that's handling the applying
the Dom divs and sending you the UI
events back
well let's switch this back to web
assembly okay know what happens if we
refresh the application okay now you see
that loading thing again so floating
slower so it's downloading more stuff if
we have twelve in the browser and look
at the what was downloaded we can see
just by just by tweaking one little
thing on the server we're back to
downloading a web assembly dot at
runtime and all the dll's
so we're keeping the component model the
same while enabling a new scenario where
you can do server-side hosting of your
applications so like I said because this
is much less experimental there's not a
dotnet runtime that we're still need to
build and mature we think we can just go
ahead and make this available to in
dotnet core three Oh which we hope to
have a as we do that that integration
with asp.net core to make sure that's
clear that this is really separate from
the you know Donna in the browser effort
we've decided to rename this feature and
call it Razer components so a
server-side blazer is we're gonna be
calling Razer components and it will
ship with asp.net core three oh we
expect to get a preview of that out
probably like early next year right well
what else is new well we're not we're
not stopping we still continue to work
on blazer blazer 0.6 is the next release
that we're working on we have new
features that are coming in that release
template components is one where you can
write components that like for like a
grid or a ListView that you can specify
templates for so how they render and
then we're also updating the server-side
render plays or supports so that you can
integrate with the azure signal our
service see if I can do demo template
lis components really really fast to do
that I'm gonna hop over to a preview
version of Visual Studio I have a little
application here that just renders a
list of pets so I have a component pet
component then I'm rendering a list of
pets with
let's see what that pet component looks
like it's right here so it takes in as a
parameter an ienumerable of pet and then
it renders the pet name for each pet and
if we look at how that's called nothing
yeah in in the pages index like CS HTML
you can see here's where the dummy data
is being set up and then we're calling
the pets list component and passing in
the pets but I'd like to be able to
change how these things are rendered
well because let's actually update the
pets list to have now a template that we
can use and it looks very similar to how
we captured child content before except
instead of just render fragment we're
going to capture a regna fragment of pet
because it's going to be a parameterised
template let's call this pets template
and then now instead of just rendering
at pet and then just the name we're
going to render the whole pets template
right here in that list item then when
we consume the component now we can
define a template as a child element of
our pets list so let's do that if we can
really quick and I think I have a in say
for the sake of time I've got the
template already authored down here it
looks like this so all this is I think
it's pets template as I what I changed
it to in the when I just type it there
we go
so you can see that this lights up so
this is now a child element of pets list
and you can have multiple of these and
we're specifying the mark-up that we'd
like to use to render each pet I can
have a parameter that's it's the context
parameter that I can name it's called
pet and it's of type pet as we iterate
through each pet in the component so
let's let's go and refresh now and see
if we get a slightly better view with my
new fancy template that I just added
you could do it all right we're
reloading is rebuilt reloading aah
I messed up something what did I mess up
that's the effects component pet that
that uh so close out of toy pets
template I do right here it looks like
it's so close I don't know well well hop
to the bug that I apologize but we're
pretty much out of time so lot still to
do to get to take blazer to not be an
experimental project lots of runtime
work so not ready for production quite
yet but we hope you found it exciting
blazer 0.6 will ship this month and
we'll have ongoing blazer releases
monthly and then in early to 2019 we
hope to have a preview of the Razr
components work here's some additional
resources go and check out the blazer
down at site to download the bits you
can find the code on github lots of
stuff in the community that you should
definitely check out and feel free to
chat with us on git er and that's blazer
thank you for watching today and I hope
you enjoyed it